sa collègue bonsoir bonsoir lui en soit
sony mais on peut allumer camara
tentation ouais bah ouais quel intérêt
je m'inspire des grands aînés mais voilà
j'y vais bientôt y arriver alors on peut
dire en tous les cas que vous avez
réussi votre réhabilitation patrick
bruel parce que vous avez sorti un album
qui s'appelle juste avant qui a vendu
1,7 million d'exemplaires
c'est énorme c'est patent millions 7 qui
était louable c'est le sait là c'est
l'accueil qualitatif sur le web qui
était très intéressant mais le million 7
et 13 niveaux oui ça c'est mieux qu'un
coup de poing dans la gelée travers
cette ses disques de quoi c'est oui ou
non et qui y en a également
c'est énorme c'est très rare en france
sacré come back donc maintenant c'est
bienvenu c'était plus facile pour vous
d'analyser ce qui s'était passé cette
espèce de flottement qui a eu à un
moment entre votre premier pic de
carrière et celui que vous connaissez
actuellement de parler creux de la vague
pendant lesquels tu ne vendait que 500
milles à l'heure
non c'est le disons la la perception un
peu un peu décalée entre entre ce que je
voulais donner artistiquement et ce qui
était perçu qui était à mon avis
peut-être beaucoup plus sociologique
c'est devenu un phénomène sociologique
plus qu'un phénomène artifices qui va au
sort n'a été publiée qui avaient des
chances méchants sont garés et qui avait
calé juste juste un peu de café de la
musique avait un piano une guitare les
chansons un public et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il ya eu un petit peu de calme un
petit peu de dos rond se ressourcer un
peu faire cet album revenir sur scène
avec un spectacle assez simples
justement pour pour mettre en valeur la
musique c'était quoi le pire moment
pendant cette éclipse
ça a été d'avoir la sensation entre 84
94 et 95 que quoi que je fasse quoi que
je sors voilà ça pouvait pas trouvé
grâce aux yeux des gens et quand j'ai eu
l'impression au jour de deux blocs et ça
suffit ça mérite plus que ça même été
plus loin peut-être simplement je me
suis dit bon bah je vais aller me faire
plaisir et j'ai de la chance c'est c'est
de faire d'autres choses aussi ses
pouvoirs lehmann pouvant détourner le
jaguar oui et pouvoir partir trois mois
en amazonie pour
pour se ressourcer c'est ma patrie allez
les gens vous foutez la paix c'est
plutôt bien vous étiez sûr que ça
remarche ray non ouais non bien sûr
d'abord on n'est jamais sûr puisque clip
est alors un moment pas comme ça non ggg
pas flipper j'ai eu envie de retrouver
le plaisir
mon plaisir l envie là ça me faisait
flipper d'éventuellement perdre ce
plaisir et séquence est revenue ça a été
ça a été magnifique
bah oui vous êtes retourner au charbon
recontacte avec le public enfin bon j'ai
eu un gros déclic au stade de france
ouais quand j'anime invite à chanter
avec lui je me suis retrouvé sur cette
scène où je savais pas trop comment ce
qui allait se passer j'ai vu cette
agression c'est 85 mille personnes se
lever puis ces trois minutes assez
magique que j'ai passé avec lui ça
m'arrivait de montrécourt et j'ai eu
envie de me remettre donc là les
maquettes sont allés plus vite les
champions serait une arme tout allait
mal vie en art on a retravaillé on sait
on sait bien j'ai bien enfermer bien
isolé pour bosser pour être près de 100
pour être pour ne pas avoir de ils ont
deux points de référence travail
complètement librement sans aucune
aucune cible
oui c'était peut-être ça le plus un peu
de marketing et aucun et bien c'est
faire l'album l'album appartenait à
aucune aucune aucune mode aucune
tendance qu'une vague
sinon d'essayer de faire des chansons et
de voir ce qu'elle allait ce qu'elle lui
avait donné en tout cas c'est vrai qu'à
la veille de la sortie de l'album
c'était le 18 octobre 99 j'étais jean
menait pas large mais je me demandais un
peu où ça allait aller mais par contre
j'étais assez content j'étais content
d'avoir cette cet objet avec ses
chansons mais bon ça me ressemble
maintenant on connaît le résultat à
milan cède donc je vais faire cent
cinquante cinq concerts alors ça
continue tout l'été alors c'est très
effectivement cela de beyrouth à la
roche sur yon non on arrête et on sait
pas mais pas l'art sur yon de sécurité
la roche sur yon et abusent de leur
gouvernance et jamais à la roche sur yon
non les annuler le concert au liban qui
devait avoir lieu la semaine prochaine
ce concert visiblement d'après les
messages que je reçois pas toujours très
tendre
or tous beaucoup de sensibilité d'un
côté comme de l'autre et j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya que c'est pas du
tout prix comme j'avais l'intention de
le faire c'est à dire c'est simplement
moi personnellement je conseille mais là
ça n'a pas l'air d'être le cas du tout
et peut-être comme moi j'ai mal mesuré
le ce que ce que
la position exactement cette région mais
j'ai pas bien mesuré c'est pourtant je
regarde ces choses là mais là non j'ai
l'impression d'espacé pour les gens ce
qu'il ya un effet d'annonce là bas ils
sont tout content qu'ils aient des
artistes qui viennent finalement ils
viennent pas du mois mais sur ce coup là
c'est au delà de au delà de ça il ya des
raisons de sécurité personnelle ainsi
bien là bas qu'ici que je peux pas
mettre en péril ni moi ni les gens
proches de moi nulle musiciens nîmes et
minimes et techniciens attendus rassurez
moi il accable concert à porcieu
pourcieux c'est clair bon ben si on
pouvait constater le lecteur parce que
votre succès qu'a mentionné comme un
rôle sur you tube de l'année dernière
déjà bon j'ai eu pour se poursuit à côté
de lyon dans l'isère alors toute cette
tournée est gravé dans le marbre
ça donne l'occasion d'un double album où
c'est comment on fait un
si moi je le fais mais sur ma promo sexe
magouille et culture générale
ce mec est d'amener gorille c'est
incroyable en fait c'est nul
alors voilà donc le double cd s'appelle
rien ne s'efface diddy en écoutant
on le sait
mais je crois
histoire de
tous les mots qui viennent
sans téléphone
c'est que chez les fruits et près du
corps elle
je t'aime
j'te mentirais
je te disais j'ai pas pensé
je te disais j'ai pas voulu
salut je ne sais pourquoi elle allait
danser né à saint jean au musette et
quand cela lui a pris 1 vvl frissonner
était chipé comment ne pas en perdre la
tête
c'est réparé des braves audacieux car on
croit toujours au doux mots d'amour
quand ils ont dit avec les yeux
qu'il aimait tant elle ne trouvait plus
aux agents et
rester 10 et sans volonté sous serre
les femmes
tu verras tout seul
on s'était dit rendez vous dans dix ans
je vous aime
non
sur l'année
j'avais ici
m
explorer
la halle est une chance
m
bon
ce sont là
si bas
bonjour
pourquoi
m
revenir
et
appelée
programme
et la blanche
voilà patrick bruel ayem c'est pas bien
non